good morning guys in this video i'm
going to talk about what i dislike about
america after living abroad for six
years
last video was about the positives now
the negatives
and a little background traveled to 85
countries
lived in four
and one caveat this all comes from my
personal experience
when comparing countries it's tough
there's not one label you can put on
places
uh nothing you know what i'm saying
doesn't apply to everyone obviously
so good knowing that it's not black and
white there's a lot of gray here
but i'm gonna bring you into the main
things that stick out to me after coming
back to the states number one
media
wow it's really gone
down the toilet the mainstream media in
this country
really bad if it was nutrition
it would be the choice between captain
crunch
and fruit loops
and imagine trying to be an athlete
living off that diet well the media is
sort of like that in the in the
knowledge space of what the world is
like and what the country is like
they're doing a huge huge
disservice for our collective psyche
they're not interested in our
psychological well-being they're not
interested in in building a better
country they're only interested in ad
revenue and division
division and negativity
makes more money so i think in a hundred
years or so people are going to look
back on society and say wow
there was actually a point in time where
the model of the media was to pit people
against each other through half truths
through fear through manipulation by
doing so they'd make more money
and by also doing so the end result is
they do
detrimental harm to society
and they're going to look back and say
wow what was wrong with those people in
that's how i feel right now the media in
a way a lot of the media is like a brand
that's sold out i think of my samsonite
bag i used to have i had it for 12 years
this thing was properly abused all over
the world
and finally finally it quit but i got 12
years of use out of it it's really good
bag
and i'm like well that's a great brand i
think i'll
i think i'll buy another one of these
bags
in week two
on my samsonite bag the wheel fell off
and i
lost all my
good feelings about that brand i feel
that's the same for a lot of the big
names in media
who even five years ago and definitely
10 years ago
had credibility
were looking for objective truth
wanted to do the right thing had
integrity
out the window now the good thing about
this is i think
many people are waking up to this fact
number two politicians politicians are
doing a wonderful job
dividing us americans
and so whether it be the nancy pelosi's
or the mitch mcconnell's
they're pretty much the same people they
do not have our interest in mind they
have their interests in mind they have
their backers interests in mind
and so what they're doing is putting us
against each other
when what we should be doing
is collecting ourselves
and going against them
number three curiosity
a lot of americans are curious but a lot
aren't and it's easy to get stuck
in our information silos in our cultural
silos happens for me and the longer i'm
i'm away from society the longer i'm on
the internet
it's like my curiosity
dissolves to some degree
you know i find myself looking in the
same spaces you know we get stuck in our
digital realities which
look i've found
do not match
uh what's going
on you know on the streets in america
downtown san francisco today this is
sunday morning
it's really quiet these days lots shut
down
and
it doesn't look much different on monday
morning
okay four racism this last year we've
been told america is one of the most
racist places on the planet
uh well at least the media is telling us
that
the very interesting thing is when i get
on the ground here whether that could be
in the in the south bronx
in new york city
i could be in
queens
where it's mostly southeast asians
uh it could be with the hasidic jews
every different group here
zero problems connecting talking with
people on a on an equal level zero
tension between us being from different
backgrounds and so to be told that you
know we're all pitted against each other
if you look online
um you know at the news well it's it's
it's not how i felt
on the ground as far as coming from a
different background
and making it happen in this country and
not being excluded
i i do believe if you're if you want it
bad enough and you're hard-working
this place lets you achieve what you
want to achieve
with the least amount of tension
from being from from somewhere else and
i'm not discrediting anyone's
racist experience that happens it's
disgusting it sucks we need to get to
less of that
but overall america is one of the least
racist countries i've been to number
five
fear the us lives in a lot of fear
i think more than any country i've been
to
people fear sometimes the littlest
things
now there is a reason to be
fearful of what's going on in society
and if you lost your job and if you're
broke
there's legitimate reasons to be fearful
about life but there are also other
reasons i mean sometimes people
uh
make the biggest issue out of something
that shouldn't even exist for example
i know a guy he was talking about going
uh
going into nature like getting out of
this
out of the cities because of covet i
said go to go to joshua tree national
park it's beautiful
and there's there are all these dirt
roads in the north side of it not many
people go to you can really get away
from people get lost
and he's like well
what if i get a flat tire
he's got a new suv
okay
you get a flat tire what happened do you
change it
okay
is that the worst thing that happens you
put the spare on or maybe you have to
call someone
whatever anyways
in my opinion
quite an unnecessary
fear fear with the covid i mean it's
it's
it's nothing anyone's happy about there
are people
dying there are people suffering from it
it's a real issue
but for example in this environment
when there's zero
chance of me getting covered
do i need to be fearful right now
no
the interesting thing is there are a lot
of people
that uh at least it seems to be in my
neighborhood
that are even fearful in these
environments or if someone's you know 30
feet away with both people with a mask
on
you know they're they're scared you can
see it in their eyes number six
lack of purpose slash meaning
i think that's a western world problem
at the moment
you know what do we what do we find
meaning and it's it's tough especially
now when we're locked inside
and and stuck on the digital
platforms like
what's what's the purpose of it all and
if you don't have religion or some like
very firm
beliefs that you follow you know what
gets you up every day and gives you
purpose and that's a that's a tough
problem society is dealing with right
now
i think that's you know everyone has to
find
a purpose slash meaning and it's it's
it's specific to them but if you don't
have that
i think things can be very difficult and
very alienating and isolating right now
number seven entitled mentality
there's a lot of entitlement here
caveat a lot of people are truly
suffering like truly out on their luck
truly
truly in a terrible position i'm not
talking about them i'm talking about the
people that talk about how bad their
life is
as they sit in a nice apartment
watching netflix
ordering takeout
that type of entitlement there seems to
be a lot of that there's also
entitlement at the very high end
uh you know too big to fail mentality so
if you know a company
took their risks whether that be a big
bank an airline
or whatever when things are good and
then when things aren't so good they're
bailed out
number eight healthcare now if i have
brain surgery i'm i'm quite happy to be
here in the us
excellent doctors great health care
facilities
but on the insurance side of things
it's quite ridiculous
so
abroad
i paid 12 no 1100 a year i had a health
care plan that covered
every country in the world even iran of
all places right but every country i
could even come back and go to the best
healthcare and best hospitals in the
united states
and so it was eleven hundred dollars and
my deductible was two thousand
now back here
five hundred dollars a month
and a 7 000
deductible for those that don't know the
deductible language it means basically
your insurance doesn't even start paying
doesn't it doesn't start working until
you spend 7 thousand out of pocket first
and then it starts working even though
you're paying the five hundred dollars a
month
so
that seems to be a problem
uh
no political party really wants to fix
there's too much money to be made in it
number nine free speech
so i've been to countries where people
are limited in what they can say usually
it has to do with politics
so you're you're in a great conversation
and then there's like this tenseness you
can feel
and you can tell that the person wants
to continue speaking but they're scared
of speaking
that is a detrimental thing to one's
health to one's health to one's
sovereignty
and it's something as a country i know
the topics come up this last year quite
a bit
is very important it's very important
that we're able to speak as we think
because repressing it
from what i've seen in the world doesn't
lead to anything good and then there's
also the the cultural side of free
speech where people are so scared to
stay true to their tune
uh that that let's just say they kill
the music and they sound like everyone
else it's quite obnoxious just just to
hear like this monologue of of thought
about certain issues
uh you know what's deemed to be
appropriate or correct
and
the fear back to fear
that a lot of people have of just
speaking true to their mind and and look
there are serious consequences
unfortunately now i'm not in corporate
america thank god uh but if you are you
know there's consequences with your job
it's a very dangerous place to be in
free speech we have it in this country
it's a beautiful thing
we need to not let it slip
number 10 cycles of poverty whether that
be inner city america parts of inner
city america appalachia
different parts of the country people
are definitely
left out in the cold economically and
these are deep complex issues
but nobody no politicians seem to really
want to address
this problem we have in the country i
think the reason is
it's going to go way beyond an election
cycle it's going to take way too much
work it's going to take
decades i think to truly address the
problem and so it's almost like a new
deal
type of effort that needs to take place
so when you have you know rampant drug
addiction lack of skills education all
these things
this takes a lot of time and again the
politicians like to
pit us against each other
versus address that problem doesn't
matter what side of the aisle nobody
seems to really really deeply care
about that issue in this country
and
after walking so many of these streets
in our cities and
so many of the streets in different
cities around the world
we have a problem
and
look it's complicated if someone's
into drugs
if they're addicted how do you get them
off i mean my dad quit alcohol you know
when he wanted to quit alcohol it's not
from
whatever anyone said to him
and that's the case for a lot of people
and then is if you have you know not
even uh you know the ability to write or
english language skills people need
purpose back to purpose right they need
employment okay what's that job going to
be they need housing obviously they need
they need training they need some sort
of family
community
uh the only way out of this is to put a
massive effort forward so there's also
you know people that are in these
communities
that where they don't have opportunity
you might just have to leave i did i
moved out of
the countryside of vermont
i don't know what i would do there
uh for work
right so
you know the the good thing i will say
is in the u.s if you have the skills
you can move
and figure something out
it's not like there's a lack of
opportunity
it's just if you don't have the skills
what do you do okay san francisco this
is uh
this is probably the best place to be
homeless if there's such a thing this is
the best place to be homeless because
they're the most is given to them
that's not a solution it just attracts
more homelessness
uh it doesn't fix an actual problem
so we need to get to the to the ground
level
of this issue as a country
uh that that really pains me to come
back because it's only getting worse
and again
the politicians
don't seem to really care
about the deep dive on this issue
number 11 sellouts feel like there are a
lot of sellouts in this culture
and that could be online just pushing
fear narrative nonstop i know this is a
negative video but this is about as
negative as i get usually i'm an
optimist with my content but the fear
narrative
pitting people against one another
that's pretty profitable
you have the nba
selling out to china hollywood selling
out to china not holding any values or
principles but just selling out for
money obviously
it's really sad to see that in this
country because it's actually
it's a that's a corrosive energy that
harms all of us number 12 lack of
compassion empathy
i've always found the us to be a very
friendly
open place
but it's it's it's definitely the most
tense at the moment
and
you know understanding where someone is
coming from you know why they vote for a
certain person why would they do that
you know just just having the curiosity
to see what are their motives behind
what they do
and
not coming in from i'm better than you
you have to defend yourself but come in
from i'm interested in you i want to
know why you think this way
and quite often when you hear someone
out
it makes a lot of sense but we're living
in an illusion some somewhat right now
we're all seeing the world
through what's being presented to us
through a screen
and everyone has an objective
and knowing what that objective is
is a good thing
and back to the news it's like not
always what they're reporting it's quite
often what they're
not reporting and why are they not
reporting that story
and it's because they haven't they have
an objective they want to they want you
to think a certain way
and what's my objective here my
objective is in this channel
i want you to see the world that you
know on a tangible ground level
and and make your own opinion i don't
want to force it
whatever down your throat and tell you
how to think with that said i have a
view of the world i'm mostly an optimist
i like i like different people from
different places i like different
stories
and there might be a bias in that
but i'll be straight up with you on that
my my goal and my objective is to
complete to be completely authentic
as
best as i can be
and not try to hide
the truth it's
the search for truth which is somewhat
of a moving target
as we know number 13
covid the covid divider i'd like to call
it it's like this this pandemic should
have brought us together like why would
it not bring us together we all have to
deal with it
no one's immune from it
but it's actually done the opposite it's
become politically political
unfortunately
and in my neighborhood in san francisco
wow it's like it's lost all humanity
nobody looks at each other everyone
seems to be scared of one another even
going on a hiking trail can be stressful
even when you're massed up like i when
i'm around people i'll go messed up
but
even with that
people look at you as like a threat it's
like come on guys
we
we all have to deal with this nobody
wants to
so let's smile at each other
say hi
be compassionate
it's really something that should bring
us together and not be a a political
thing for example
i have my mask down
you know if i'm 100 feet away from
someone outside fine i'm having my mask
down i'm not wearing it and uh someone
called me a trump supporter because i
had my pass down and it's like okay
even if i was
uh which i'm not
uh what what the hell does that have to
do with my mask
[Music]
at all it's ridiculous
yeah let's get beyond this stupidness
we're in right now
so you live down here though yeah i've
been here for 25 years
what's the feel what's the feel at the
moment uh so the feel at the moment is
you know like i said it's a ghost town
literally all of these buildings you see
downtown every single one of them all
the way down from basically fifth street
down to the embarcadero are literally
completely empty including salesforce
tower facebook tower
my building which is right next to
salesforce wow they're all totally empty
and you know they spent all that money
and all those billions of dollars on
building all these skyscrapers
now they sit empty and they're literally
telling everybody it's a new
work-at-home world and get used to it
and you're never going to leave your
house now and stay in lockdown
7-eleven is closed oh my god the
7-eleven that's supposed to be open 24
7. i don't think i've ever seen it
closed in 25 years you can't even go in
there and get anything done i mean
literally everything is just closed it's
a total ghost so you think people do you
think people will go back to work in
these towers eventually or what's
they're saying only about 40 are gonna
go back and it's everything's indefinite
right now that's what i there's no like
clear end at the end yeah there's no
light at the end of it i mean i've been
working for all these tech companies for
decades and they're all saying like yeah
we don't see this ending anytime soon
just stay at home for the near future
they're saying for at least a year
yeah and this is sad the crime is on the
up this is how we met just over this
memorial so from my understanding some
guy was led out of prison who shouldn't
have committed many crimes this poor
woman was killed in a car accident
because he hit her
i think that's the case but that's cool
people are bringing flowers
that's one bit of hope of society look
at these buses
nobody riding them
as you can see these streets nobody
walking them either
more than anything is just sort of a
documentation of history
those are my big negatives i also have a
video about the positives i'll leave a
link at the end here
and i do want to say
overall
america is a wonderful place it's a
great country going through an odd time
and another odd thing is i'm actually
more pro-american now than any time
before in my life despite
uh all the division this despite which
seems to be all the hate
uh look we're getting games
we are getting gamed by our politicians
and by our media
americans
through and through
the vast majority
are cool want to connect
want to get along it doesn't matter the
political party
doesn't doesn't matter the background
like that is the beauty of this country
we're getting gamed
we're waking up to it i think
slowly waking up to it
we got better days ahead
and uh
look
more people immigrate here than than
than any other country in the world and
it's not because it sucks it would suck
people win they just wouldn't come here
uh people move because they want to
better their lives
and so
despite our big problems right now and
i'm not undermining those and i can be
very honest and sober and say
we do have big problems
i believe in this country
better days ahead thanks for coming
along guys i got a patreon page
a link at the end here if you want to
support the channel
and uh much more to come
about different uh
sub communities different
uh corners of the country that i'm gonna
get into over this next year all right
have a great day until the next one